so there's more women than men in the  world anyway so there's going to be more  single women it's going to be that way  because there is less men in um yeah  less men in the world  um if you want to have certain  requirements as a woman you either have  to be of a certain standard yourself and  I mean when I mean standard I mean the  way you carry yourself you know if your  body is what you lead with then that's  all men just look at you as a physical  object and they will exploit that  because that's what men do and not all  men but if you're going to advertise  your body that's what men are going to  look at and if you want you know a lot  of women they will do only fans and that  kind of thing and then when they get to  an age where they're no longer relevant  younger girls are coming up better than  them then they want to turn around and  say thank god oh please you know take me  now